[Music]
I hope you like apple pie all right miss
al you were so sassy and almost
calculated in this movie which was so
opposite of how I feel like you are yeah
how did you get into that headspace it
was really fun the first email I got
from Sophia she said I can't wait for
you to play the bad girl in this so and
also I think I'm a little no I have I
felt like I got to be a little funny
like in this film so I I love Church
definitely rebellious and this was your
first movie on your own like after
joining 18 right yeah it was I didn't
have to do school on set like I normally
always had to and I'm so used to being
the child you know the little one on the
movie so yeah and I didn't go with my
mom it was like the first thing I went
without a family member so it was a
perfect one I had worked with Nicole and
Kirsten and Sophie obviously so I felt
very safe can I get you anything
give me the key you know what control we
gotta talk about mr. Colin Farrell you
had some steamy scenes with him how is
that it's good yeah I love how giggly
are getting right now oh my god I
remember like Sophie and I both were
blushing when I had like the seat like
the scene in particular they kind of
like sneak in and kiss him but also
Colin is totally comfortable nothing
weird at all he's super cool about it
made you feel fine but I'll see you're
like oh god like I'm kissing Colin
Farrell well on a scale of one to ten on
the kissing scale yet oh I can't say
easy but a 10 yeah also but also like
he's like sleeping right so like how
good yeah he's a great like sleeping yes
sir Elle Fanning is all grown up in the
beguiles out in select theaters this
weekend the 19 year olds also talked to
eg about growing up in the spotlight
with older sister Dakota what does it
like to have each other to lean on as
you grow up in Hollywood oh it's really
nice I think my sister also we've gotten
I think even closer we're sisters still
but we're also like friends it's nice
that someone can understand
you yeah going through it's great so are
we ever gonna see you and her in a movie
like my sister yeah yeah I mean I hope
so that would be really it would have to
be something perfect though like I but
we have been looking like we definitely
want to who knows when it will happen
though I guess it could be any time but
yeah hopefully one day that's something
we want to do
[Music]